la douleur elle m'est devenu très
familière ces derniers temps
celle qu'on ressent quand on est sans
cesse blessé par la même personne
tu fais que parler du système depuis
jour où je t'ai rencontré site est
l'accueil aller avec toi j'espérais
quand déménagerait à londres après la
remise des diplômes et comment j'étais
essentielle du genou
il n'y a que dans ses rares moments où
il m'attire contre sa poitrine et me
fait des promesses qui n'est jamais
capable de tenir
la douleur disparaît à série 1
tu
sb revenez plus tard
les relations amoureuses c'est compliqué
tu as un super job qui t'attend au
seattle mais là-bas pour moi y'a rien tu
m'aurais moi ok mais ça suffit pas si je
ne suffit pas c'est ton problème mais tu
ne vas pas m'arrêter
j'abandonne patients atteints pour toi
alors tu me fais payer
[Musique]
tu fais ça tout le temps tu gâches tous
les bons moments passés ensemble rhône
je suis pas en train de cacher un bon
moment j'ai juste sortie numéro d'un
autre mec de tes affaires s'est pas
défilé avec iph être annoncés pas être
ami avec toi tu voles plein mais non
je sais pas quand c'est vrai ça ne l'est
pas
ça suffit on redémarre est lorsque nous
aimons nous sommes tous des idiots je
voulais de guerrier
tu es l'endroit que je préfère thèse